[Aplausos]
por más de 10 años he desarrollado
tecnología en el ámbito espacial
esto es lanzadores y satélites satélites
y vehículos lanzadores estas naves
espaciales nos imponen determinadas
condiciones a la hora de trabajar las
fundamentales que las cosas no pueden
fallar tengamos en mente que todo va
estar en el espacio y no tenemos
posibilidad de reparar los equipos no
tenemos posibilidad de cambiar las cosas
la segunda es que esta tecnología es
considerada estratégica para los países
industriales lo cual significa que la
información de cómo desarrollar un
equipo para un satélite o para un
vehículo lanzador va a circular en forma
muy escaso directamente no va a circular
en el mundo científico y la tercera es
que nos exige posicionarnos en la
frontera del conocimiento en muchas
disciplinas todo esto requiere una
mirada ingenieril muy estricta la
primera y fundamental no apartarnos del
método científico la segunda es trabajar
con normas con estándares obviamente
realizar cálculos simulaciones
mediciones trabajar siempre por
procedimiento
todo lo que hagamos todas las decisiones
que tomemos los pasos que debemos las
acciones tienen que quedar documentadas
tenemos que ser revisados por otros
especialistas por pares de la comunidad
nacional de la comunidad internacional
tenemos que someter nuestras creaciones
a ensayos ambientales tengamos en cuenta
que todo lo espacial va a estar sometido
en un ambiente muy agresivo tenemos
radiación cósmica temperaturas muy altas
temperaturas muy bajas condiciones de
vacío bueno nosotros tenemos que
garantizar que nuestras creaciones van a
poder sobrevivir a eso entonces todo
esto evidentemente no da mucho lugar a
la ambigüedad sin mucho lugar a la
planificación
todas nuestras intenciones deben estar
convertidos o deben convertirse en
requerimientos y estos requerimientos
tienen que estar vinculados a números y
pongamos esto un ejemplo tengo un
satélite que está a 600 kilómetros sobre
la tierra y necesito comunicarme desde
el espacio así hacia una estación
terrena que va a estar por ejemplo en
argentina entonces eso es un
requerimiento bien concreto de mi
desarrollo la no información sin embargo
la no información sobre cómo tengo cómo
puedo desarrollar este equipo me pone en
una posición en un punto de
incertidumbre y tenemos que afrontar un
gran problema y lo vamos a afrontar
partiendo este gran problema en pequeños
problemas en problemas más manejables
que nos permitan transitar de alguna
forma desde esa incertidumbre absoluta a
alguna certidumbre y en términos de
incertidumbre me pregunto por qué estoy
compartiendo el espacio con alguien que
está pintando
muy buenas tardes vamos a ver por qué
estamos compartiendo este espacio en
verdad nosotros también los que estamos
dentro del arte también trabajamos con
esa incertidumbre estamos siempre
trabajando en la frontera de lo conocido
de la creatividad porque para crear
claramente tenemos que estar trabajando
y caminando sobre ese abismo que nos
mantiene con estas incertidumbres que
estás hablando estoy consciente de que
el arte y la ciencia tienen sus lugares
opuestos pero también deben tener sus
coincidencias
creo que el mundo en donde nos movemos
es un mundo de caos un mundo de desorden
en que todo el tiempo estamos tratando
de decodificar lo y tratar de
vincularnos de alguna manera y generar
léxicos en común o códigos en común que
nos permitan
establecer una comunicación el arte
trabaja con la comunicación nosotros
somos comunicación sí o sí entonces
cuando yo estoy creando asumo ese caos y
asumo también de que la realidad es una
construcción cultural la realidad es una
construcción cultural quizás haya otra
clase de realidad no lo sé pero la
nuestra es una construcción cultural en
esa idea del caos por ejemplo mi método
de trabajo tiene que ver con una especie
de impulso interior de catarsis parece
algo individual que estoy hablando o un
episodio particular pero en verdad todos
los artistas tienen diferentes
estratégicos estrategias esta tiene
también historia también tenemos métodos
viene del automatismo psíquico del
surrealismo de generar impulsos sobre mí
más viscerales sobre la materia sobre el
bastidor en este caso
con esos impulsos después llega un
momento de orden de buscar un orden en
lo que vamos construyendo y que la
pintura aparece que ya quedó estática
termino la pintura no pasa más nada pero
como dije anteriormente la pintura o la
obra de arte jamás va a quedar estática
porque es un sistema comunicacional y
necesita de otras personas para que se
cumpla ese ciclo este sistema
comunicacional es tremendamente complejo
mi obra está quieta pero por ejemplo voy
a dar un ejemplo de una artistas
argentinos
el grupo escombro es un artista son un
grupo de artistas que en el 2001 crisis
económica argentina tomaron un pan ni
siquiera lo hicieron tomaron un pan y lo
envolvieron en alambres de púa no tengo
nada que explicar con relación a la
simbología que tiene eso en la crisis
del 2001 pero ahora imaginemos que esa
obra ya está quieta dice lo mismo
siempre no nunca dice lo mismo esa obra
la llevó a otro país con otro contexto
con otros espectadores la pongo en
jerusalén
en jerusalén un pan envuelto en púas
espinas claramente también tiene otro
mensaje imagínense también si lo llevo a
un lugar de fronteras entre un país rico
y un país pobre alambre de púas y
alimentos siempre va a tener otro
sentido porque la obra necesita un
contexto la obra nunca va a estar quieta
y también necesita de un espectador
que también va cambiando y acá se me
complica tremendamente porque porque
todas son variables nada está quieto
todo está dentro del caos
las personas tampoco somos estamos acá y
nosotros decimos si nos definimos como
los definieron acá y tampoco vamos a
hacer así
el contexto va a cambiar pero las
personas tampoco somos nos vamos
construyendo y reconstruyendo entonces
también tenemos otra cuestión no somos
las mismas personas cuando miramos una
obra que si la miramos diez años después
o un año después nos ha pasado con la
música generalmente es más fácil
entonces las personas no somos vamos
siendo y yo quería traer acá la charla a
leonardo davinci porque es el emblema
tal vez de la fusión entre ciencia y
arte leonardo davinci en 1495 voy a
decir números como vos
en 1495 en pintó la última escena en
milán
en esa época ciencia se podía pintar
anatómicamente por primera vez las
personas y leer un campo en eso se puso
a estudiar a todas las personas la
última escena tiene una estructura muy
científica y en el uso de la perspectiva
que era un recurso que se utilizó que
que se empezaba a usar en el 1300 1400 y
el estudio anatómico puso
o a buscar personas para que posen para
los apóstoles y para jesús entonces se
fue a la plaza de milán un día soleado y
hermoso y vi a un joven a un joven que
se juntaba a los estereotipos de lo que
uno considera la belleza de esa época
entonces dijo mire yo soy un pintor soy
leonardo da vinci le voy a dar 30
educados era la moneda del momento sí
porque no posa para mí para hacer de
jesucristo y el hombre y como encantado
o esposo tardó tres años en hacer la
obra cuatro grupos de tres personas y
último elige a pintar a judas esto creo
que es real esa clase de realidad que
describió antes esto es entonces dice
donde buscó a judas acá la historia
confirmable dice que la busca o en una
prisión o en un burdel yo voy por la
idea del burdel porque me gustaba
el concepto lúgubre de la idea no me
gusta más algún reciclado
e
el tema es que va a leonardo temeroso se
mete al burdel de milán tres años
después de estar con la obra y dice ve a
un hombre atormentado en un rincón con
cicatrices con todo
a pesar de este tipo es ideal para hacer
de judas
entonces se acerca temeroso yo calculo
que fue así estoy seguro y le dice mire
discúlpeme soy un pintor estoy pintando
la última escena no le gustaría ganarse
30 educados y pisa y posar para ser de
y el hombre lo mira y le dice sí como no
me va a molestar ganar otros 30 educados
y hace tres años fui el que posó para
jesucristo es verdad
la sociedad actual nos requiere sin duda
especialistas sin embargo eso nos
posiciona en un punto de dilema la
biblioteca profunda a veces puede ser
una biblioteca angosta hace unos años a
una clase de introducción a la física a
mi pregunta y que era la física una de
mis alumnas del fondo hizo este gesto lo
cual para mí fue doloroso y desde ese
momento intentó poner algún énfasis en
demostrar o convencer de alguna forma
que el especialista tiene que estar o
tiene que ser permeable a la mirada
compleja que le puede proponer o proveer
la multidisciplina sin duda que la
multidisciplina a veces lleva al choque
de culturas ahí tenemos una imagen donde
estamos en los sensores ensayos
funcionales de un satélite contra mi
compañero pintando con una banda de rock
sin duda que diferencian las vestimentas
en principio los colores las
disposiciones de la gente por un lado
estamos con copias guardapolvos botas
barbijos y por otro lado están en pijama
entonces
como dar lugar a la coexistencia a la
tolerancia a la diferencia de métodos ya
la incertidumbre y en todo caso porque
navegar es agua vivimos en un país donde
la mayoría la mayor cantidad de energía
proviene de recursos fósiles digamos de
petróleo gas carbón digamos en un 90%
eso tiene dos dilemas o dos cuestiones
directas la primera es la emisión
dióxido de carbono con el impacto que
tiene en el cambio climático y la
segunda que los recursos fósiles se
están agotando digamos que a nivel
mundial quedan alguna decena de años y
no mucho más en las reservas mundiales y
por otro lado tenemos el sol en un
ratito en un cacho nomás nos incide en
la tierra toda la energía que la
población mundial consume en un año
entonces
con estos dilemas trabajando con estos
dilemas nosotros tenemos la postura sin
duda que hay que adherir a los recursos
naturales a los recursos renovables como
son el sol el viento pero además hay
otro dato ese es el dato que me faltó
que la como el consumo en la población
está creciendo más que lo que crece la
población en sí qué quiere decir esto
que aunque utilicemos los recursos
renovables no van a alcanzar ni los
fósiles ni los renovables entonces
tenemos que adherir al sol al viento
pero también tenemos que convertirnos en
usuarios más responsables usuarios y más
inteligentes usuarios usuarios
racionales entonces entre estos dilemas
con hernán es que damos lugar a la
multidisciplina para la creación de una
escultura que está emplazada en puerto
quequén es una escultura que está
aislada de la red eléctrica y solamente
se va a iluminar que el público inyecta
de su energía de su energía corporal
mediante el giro de un timón cuando yo
gire el timón la escultura se va a
iluminar si no no
y pues pone el vídeo
bueno esa es la escultura evidentemente
girando el timón se encienden tres
puntos allí según punto azul al
principio bueno en iluminación blanca en
el centro y otra y otra azul eso se va a
dar solamente si el espectador inyecta
de su propia energía en ese sistema sino
la escultura es sin arte
bueno en relación a esta escultura en
particular hay una lógica la primera
lógica es que ningún artista debe
explicar su obra procedo explicar
el punto es es una escultura trabajada
de materiales muy genuinos es un acero
que está hecho para durar muchísimos
cientos de años y todo sale bien y
porque también queríamos como un
simbolismo de lo noble de los materiales
y el deseo de seguir estando de seguir
existiendo toda la sociedad eso tiene
que ver y por eso también es muy simple
es de un lenguaje muy directo porque
también entendemos que no es las
personas que van a una galería de arte
sino es al atravesar y te la irrumpe en
la urbanística esta escultura entonces
el lenguaje tiene que ser más directo
claramente no por eso tiene menos
profundidad lo que estamos viendo las
imágenes de estos barquitos de papel que
tienen una reminiscencia la inocencia a
la búsqueda también
de cómo parar la pelota de buscar en
este en este desorden es que hablamos al
principio y tener algo en común algo por
lo que encaminamos como sociedad y al
principio cuando yo les hablaba les
hablaba del rol del espectador bueno la
idea del espectador no solamente en el
arte en la sociedad toda debería
desaparecer porque luego lo estamos
planteando es que las personas están en
acción constantemente estamos en acción
entonces ni siquiera cuando estamos en
silencio mirando una obra de arte
eso es acción comunicacional también y
acá bajo toda evidencia estamos
absolutamente convencidos que dándole la
vuelta al timón no estamos modificando
la historia de la humanidad ni
solucionando los problemas energéticos
pero el arte sirve perfectamente para
mostrar un camino para mostrar una nueva
ética y una nueva ética que no es la
ética es una alternativa en este orden
que generábamos con el caos
en esos términos bueno la escultura está
ahí para ser visitada y creo que se
relacionado con lo del espectador si me
quiero quedar pensando en esto que esta
obra como dijo sebastián necesita de la
energía de todas las personas para
verlas si no es una obra inerte que está
muerta y pero nuestra obra tiene que ver
con la acción de las personas bueno sin
duda no podemos imaginarnos un mundo sin
un mundo sin energía sería un mundo
medieval pero tampoco podemos
imaginarnos en el camino actual con
tomando todos los recursos casi todos
los recursos fósiles y utilizando la
energía en forma poco racional
estamos convencidos con hernán que las
soluciones a estos dilemas no vendrán en
una forma integral ni de la ingeniería y
la ciencia y del arte en una forma
independiente sino que es necesaria la
fusión que converjan los esfuerzos el
esfuerzo multidisciplinar entre otras
cosas con esta escultura intentamos
crear alguna conciencia o alguna
reflexión en torno a que la generación
de energía implica un esfuerzo un gran
esfuerzo para las personas para la
comunidad y para el planeta
bueno como
como certezas pocas porque tenemos más
preguntas porque estamos en este mundo
de caos sabemos que hay una mirada
múltiple que hay que redefinir
constantemente pero hemos logrado tener
algunas conclusiones muy concretas en
principio entendemos que el arte y la
ciencia tienen que estar al servicio de
la humanidad que los productos y la
cultura y los objetos que podamos
producir tienen que estar absolutamente
democratizados para que estén al alcance
de todas las personas sí sí no pasa esto
si el arte y la ciencia no cumplen con
el fin de democratizar los que están al
alcance de toda la población solamente
estamos siendo testigos de una apuesta
de negocios y vanidad
[Aplausos]